[Musica]
buongiorno abbiamo pochissimo tempo vi
parlerò di creatività partendo da un
video
e vero che ne abbiamo avuta fin troppa
in questi giorni ma questo serve a far
capire che cosa che la creatività sono
scintille sono momenti particolari nella
vita di tutti noi che in qualche modo
cambiano la direzione alle cose cambiano
i percorsi cambiano il modo di vivere lo
stile in modi di consumare modi di
acquisti modo di acquisto
io faccio il manager quindi come voi
potete immaginare traffico e maneggio
numeri dalla mattina alla sera e spesso
molti dicono ma non ti annoia i numeri
in fondo sono noiosi non c'è nulla di
creative di creativo niente di più
sbagliato realtà che i numeri non
appaiono da soli né power point one file
excel
ma dietro i numeri ci sono i pensieri
perché altrimenti i numeri non si
realizzano
ecco perché voglio raccontarvi tre
momenti che secondo me che qualche modo
hanno anche influenzato me stesso nel
mio percorso la mia carriera nei momenti
in cui queste sciiti le hanno cambiato
un po hanno deviato il percorso della
storia
cose leggere non vi parlerò di cose
particolarmente come dire pesanti ma
aspetti che in qualche modo tutti noi
abbiamo poi subito nel nostro modo di
vivere quotidiano
questo è quello che viene chiamato il
miracolo di ben 1954 mondiali di calcio
quindi immagino che molti di voi saranno
appassionati di calcio realtà che il
miracolo da dove arriva arriva dall
inaspettato perché dietro questo
inaspettato c'è una scintilla voi
molti di voi immagino soprattutto
insomma chi soprattutto più vicino alla
parte a parte tedesca conoscerà adidas
adidas è nata in questo paesino
microscopico in mezzo alla barriera di
nome herzog enow racc spero di averlo
pronunciato bene perché ci ho messo tre
anni dopo 12 anni che lavorava in
azienda e ce l'hai fatta anche tu
ce l'ho fatta anche io in questo paesino
una cosa straordinaria che non c'è solo
ai gas
c'è anche la puma come tutti sapete due
fratelli due fratelli che come tutte le
normali famiglie e litigano e si
dividono cosa succede però in quel
momento particolare storico che la
nazionale tedesca vada
rudolf dassler e gli dice hai rudo
sponsorizza la nazionale noi
parteciperemo ai mondiali e rudolf che
ci aveva visto lungo
gli disse no e non pagherò mai nessuno
per indossare i miei prodotti sta
nazionale tedesca va dal fratello adolf
dasler dice ehi adolf visto che tuo
fratello non buone ed è stato
lungimirante voinà suoi sponsorizzare
tura nazionale si ha una condizione che
io venga in panchina con voi e seguo la
squadra perché questo perché lui grazie
a quel momento storico ha capito che per
poter giocare bene a calcio
ci vogliono delle scarpe che non
scivolino quella guarda caso è stata una
delle edizioni più piovose dei mondiali
della storia ebbene per farla breve
grazie a quell'ingegno a quel momento
storico in cui lui ha interpretato lì
nel momento in cui i giocatori giocavano
i mondiali inventò i tacchetti abitabili
delle scarpe e grazie a questo la
germania vinse anche grazie a questo la
germania vinse i mondiali che fino a
quel conto l'ungheria che fino a quel
momento era stata la squadra più forte
vedete come a volte l'ingegno arriva
dalla necessità
pioveva e lui si è inventato i tacchetti
rimovibili
in realtà poi la storia è piena di
momenti di grande creatività
forse quasi nessuno riconosce l'uomo che
qui in questa foto o forse sì quest'uomo
qui non è guglielmo marconi ma è nikola
tesla per tutti noi tesla è l'auto in
realtà lui non c'entra nulla con le auto
ma e stato l'inventore lo scopritore
della corrente alternata e non solo ma
anche delle onde radio
perché poi la storia riassegnato la
scoperta lui e non a marconi ahimé per
noi italiani ma questo è il fatto ma che
cosa ha stimolato al di là del suo genio
che cosa veramente stimolato la
creatività in quel momento storico
quindi parliamo della seconda
rivoluzione industriale
tutti noi a scuola studiamo la prima ci
dimentichiamo della seconda ciò che ha
stimolato quella scintilla di creatività
è stato il periodo il momento storico in
cui erano cambiati
gli schemi mentali geografici delle
persone non è la mia e credetemi ma è
veramente questo il punto
gli schemi mentali geografici le persone
volevano comunicare di più e velocemente
e volevano spostarsi di più e molto più
velocemente nella condizione intorno la
spinta propositiva al cambiamento ha
creato questa scintilla di innovazione
la realtà che poi oggi qualcun altro lo
ha preso ha pensato all'idea e ha poi
sviluppato un concetto che non ha nulla
a che vedere con lui non sa nulla
chiudendo ma prende solo spunto dal suo
nome la vedete come a volte la
creatività in qualche modo mantiene la
sua continuità nel tempo
il secondo momento di creatività che mi
piace raccontare è un po più vicino a me
e forse è un po più vicino anche a voi
quando i confini definiti delle cose non
sono più poi così definiti è lì che
nasce la contaminazione è un termine che
io adoro onestamente perché parlo di
continua contaminazione perché la
contaminazione è esattamente quello in
cui tutti noi oggi più o meno ci
facciamo un po i conti siamo contaminati
culturalmente siamo contaminati
geograficamente siamo contaminati
socialmente
provate a immaginare parliamo degli anni
80 quindi facciamo un salto temporale
avanti parliamo della metà degli anni 80
in cui i brand facevano i brand la
musica faceva la musica
il design faceva il design arriva un
momento storico in cui invece la
contaminazione crea tanto fervore tanta
eccitazione di creatività
ecco perché mi piace pensare che lo
sport possa in qualche modo avere
influenzato anche gli stili di vita non
solo per gli atleti ma soprattutto nel
mondo dell'einstein per la prima volta
nella storia forse voi questo magari non
lo sapete o forse non lo ricordate
ma se oggi le sneaker sono fra i
fenomeni più importanti nel mondo
dell'abbigliamento dello e quindi
dell'industria dell'abbigliamento delle
scarpe sono diventati così centrali è
perché qualcuno circa 40 anni fa 30 anni
fa decise di contaminare due mondi che
fino a quel momento erano
praticamente diviso il mondo dello sport
con quello della musica e risultante è
stata una sneaker che quella che indosso
io che ancora oggi anche marilena
indosso grazie marinella ti mando super
bacio perché se lei ancora indossa
quella scarpe grazie al genio di
qualcuno che in quel momento capii e
interpretò che certi momenti certi mondi
andavano contaminati spesso la
contaminazione viene vista insomma come
un qualcosa di addio sono impaurito cosa
succede
esco dalla mia area di comfort da realtà
che il business è fatto anche di queste
cose di innovazione di spingersi oltre
di capire che in un certo periodo
storico
qualcosa va cambiato e quella scintilla
può davvero fare il successo di un bip
di un business planetario
immaginatevi jordan giusto per essere
così per essere un po super partes mi fa
un po male devo dire adesso mi usciranno
anche delle bolle la realtà che lo
stesso fenomeno è accaduto anche con il
caso di jordan oggi è un'icona di resta
in assoluto
nasce dallo sport la scintilla è stata
quella di capire che due mondi separati
potevano unirsi e diventare un fenomeno
nei style la musica a me tanto cara è
diventata il mezzo di comunicazione e
oggi e le persone che di teli e forse
prigioni non ricorderanno sono stato il
primo e più importante gruppo hip hop
della storia che ancora oggi influenzano
continuamente le nuove generazioni e
sono ingrandirsi
uno di loro oltre tutto durante un
concerto prendeva la scarpa alzava al
cielo e diceva this is my super star e
crearono addirittura una canzone su
questo voi provate a immaginare in quel
momento storico come cambia
all'improvviso il modello di business
dell'industria che produce uno scarpe da
tennis quelli che io chiamo volgarmente
scarpe da tennis
poi la contaminazione solo questo e
design moda allora l'auto che vedete qui
è una bmw è un'auto da corsa
un'auto prestazionale o è un'opera
d'arte
in realtà non è importante darci la
risposta a quello che è importante
capire che c'è qualcosa che ci piace
dove la contaminazione arriva anche fra
il design e i prodotti di prestazione
prestazionali come un'auto da corsa così
come oggi
vedete la ricerca la ritrovo della
natura la sostenibilità si contamina
si contamina con il design con con il
col mondo dell'edilizia
noi siamo continuamente avvolti da
modelli di contaminazione ma dietro
questo c'è sempre una scintilla di
creatività che aiuta e dalla direzione
ed è una direzione inaspettata non
programmata ed è proprio questa la cosa
bella
io non amo andare nei treni non annusare
i tre li odio fortemente poi ho capito
perché nel percorso emerito capito
perché o di ogni volta andare su un
treno perché treno a due binari costanti
fissi non esci mai
invece io amo follemente i comportamenti
divergenti anche quando a volte creano
dei problemi
voglio dire mia madre sa cosa vuol dire
creare problemi io a lei ne ho creati
tanti proprio perché amo i comportamenti
divergenti poi però è questa la parte se
vogliamo un po più attuale
a volte la creatività nasce anche da un
fallimento credo che molti di voi
abbiate riconosciuto la foto che è
dietro le mie spalle
blockbuster fino a circa vent'anni fa un
fenomeno assoluto tutti lo riconoscevano
come un modello da imitare
quanti videonoleggi sono xvi si sono
creati in giro per il mondo in italia io
ricordo io sono originario di senigallia
solo senigallia ce n'erano una cittadina
a 50 mila abitanti ce ne saranno stati
almeno 20 realtà che cosa è successo
perché blockbuster è fallito perché non
è sono stati capaci di interpretare il
cambiamento il cambiamento del
consumatore
ora perché parlo di fallimento noi
abbiamo vissuto anche noi come azienda
ma tante altre
quando il brand diventa protagonista
assoluto della storia nei modelli dei
costumi del dal punto di vista proprio
del consumo c'è un problema oggi non è
più possibile
ecco perché il consumatore è diventato
il vero protagonista non è più il brand
il consumatore deve diventare e al
centro e il consumatore quello che noi
siamo chiamiamo il creato
non a caso è il consumatore che oggi
definisce quali sono le regole del gioco
il brand le asseconda le guida quando
può cerca di come dire affiancare ma
nell'immagine che vedete qui sono i
consumatori che definiscono
e creano i modelli di oggi e di domani
questo punto di vista così semplice ad
oggi sembra così semplice stato
totalmente this raptis nel mondo delle
strade della moda perché ha cambiato il
punto di vista il consumatore ha
scambiato il ruolo con i brand non devo
credo dirvi chi è questa ragazza
nell'immagine io non sono un grande fans
per influenza oggi in italia abbiamo più
influencer che persone che lavorano
realmente il punto è che oggi gli
influencer o diciamo una verità i
consumatori tracciano la riga sono loro
che guidano oggi consumatori sono delle
piccole piattaforme di comunicazione
questo si è potuto sfruttare nel miglior
modo possibile perché si ha avuto la
processo creativo di capire che il brand
da solo non poteva più comunicare aveva
visione di qualcun altro
il consumatore al centro e il
consumatore oggi vuole essere parte
delle risposte problema della
sostenibilità è un pre la conosciamo
tutti la storia delle microplastiche è
un tema molto caldo
ecco perché qui l'ingegno di capire che
nel momento in cui consumatore vuole
essere al centro e vuole essere parte
della soluzione
e normale che oggi brand in qualche modo
dialogano comunicano il consumatore
attraverso dei processi di sostenibilità
straordinari vi faccio un esempio come
la nostra azienda ma lo stanno facendo
tante altre produciamo oltre 5 milioni
di scarpe all'anno prodotte con
materiali plastici derivati dagli oceani
questo io lo trovo straordinario della
creatività a supporto del la soluzione
la soluzione che tutti noi dobbiamo in
qualche modo raggiungere perché
altrimenti moriremo non è più
sostenibile il modo in cui oggi viviamo
il consumatore vuole sentire al fianco
qualcuno che racconta le storie come se
lui che raccontasse questa è la chiave
di volta in più parliamo spesso di
social network cosa c'è di creativo nei
social network dicevamo prima
dell'influenza la realtà che cos'è un
social network che cosa sono i soci e un
aggregato di persone e bene qual è il
più grande social network
oggi esistenti tocchiamo con mano che
viviamo le città le città dovete sapere
negli ultimi anni hanno guidato
totalmente le politiche di investimento
di grandi brand oggi non si investe più
random si investe dove serve si investe
dove c'è il consumatore che può
influenzare gli altri consumatore quelli
che nel bis quello che nel business
viene chiamato l'effetto halo un effetto
domino
se io investo bene e lavoro bene a
milano sono sicuro che arrivò anche a
bolzano e ho la prova più probabilità se
lavoro bene a new york oa los angeles
suo a shanghai arrivo in tutto il resto
del mondo questo ha cambiato ancora una
volta la dinamica e la prospettiva
perché poi vedete alla fine di tutto
possiamo essere creativi possiamo essere
ingegnosi la realtà che al centro ci
sono sempre le persone quei bambini sono
creativi tanto quanto stato tesla così
quanto tanto è stato adi dassler nel
momento in cui bento i tacchetti perché
la creatività è gratis
e uno dei pochi russi oggi che è
accessibile a chiunque è uno stato
mentale è una questione di mine set
anche perché se è vero che la bellezza
salverà il mondo la creatività ci
aiuterà a farlo meglio grazie
[Applauso]